e aí galera neste campeonato você está
muito bom sabe por quê
porque hoje eu limpe a casa tu cheiroso
túnel gata cagando - fedora é porque é
muito bom ea gente meu deus do céu coisa
pra cagar onde é um gato ta fazendo meu
gato lhe peçam para ser kagawa cheiro
vocês sabem que eu recebo muitas muitas
muitas mas muitas mensagens todos os
dias às vezes nem têm tempo de responder
mas de vez em quando dou uma olhada e eu
me deparei com um tema bem legal um cara
disse que estava ficando com a menina
só que a menina estava fazendo muito
cuidou-se a destruir falar isso a menina
que é muito com dois é as pessoas que
são de fora manter mas ruins mas o que é
que é uma menina com o doce é uma menina
que passa batom garoto na boca do culto
não é uma menina que bota uma bacia de
açúcar e bota ovo dentro não ia te a
menina acordou se aquela menina que ela
fica se fazendo de difícil para ficar
atrás da minha filha só não sei se eu
quero sei não sei que isso é uma pessoa
com 12 gols aí gente não existe coisa
pior do que o menino acordou se unam e
esse menino disse que depois de um mês
já conseguiu ficava em um chute sem deco
doce não isso aí no máximo a menina
konko levemente adocicado com adoçante
eu vou contar pra vocês uma vez que o
kiss pegou a menina co2 mas essa era
cuidou sá era tão cool do estado não
podia sair de casa que juntámos beija
flor no topo dela era na escola hoje na
oitava série essa é a triste história do
dia que eu quis ficar com a menina
acordou gente eu era assim eu era assim
eu carregava no livro dela eu fazia
tarefa para ela às vezes quando ela não
sabe o assunto eu aprendi o assunto para
poder explicar para depois gente olha
como eu gostava assim o quis ficar com
essa fica disso não
eu parei por aí não porque eu queria
muito muito muito muito aquele disco de
nescau seriam eu ligava pra ela a gente
passava um a tua hora três horas
começando o celular quando ia ficar com
ela até que ela devia num quando ela
estava triste eu conversava com ela eu
queria ficar com ela antes dessa
medicinal por uns quatro anos é será
cuidou se divirtam com doze cópias líder
o cuidado de cury cacau show a cada
passagem dele não vou botar na boca
diabetes na hora doutor cheio tal silva
tia diabética chegou perto dela morreu
então meninas que estão aí por favor nos
6 5 12
se você não quer dispensa menino te
manca foi mo com a j&j ouro sai sai não
quero não disse quero não fica com esse
não sei a não ser o do chapéu onde
existe o que você é um menino que já fiz
ficar quando acordou se você é uma
menina que tem alguma amiga cuidou-se o
que conhece alguém que pudesse clique
gostei ajudar a gente acertar continuam
a fazer vídeo que o velho que a voz
estimou o vídeo 50 mil gostei povo fazer
o teste que eu faço você tá no que você
está no facebook gol muito importante
você faz é curtir esse e curtindo [ __ ]
8 mil curtir cara vamos fazer o teste
acontece é que você comente aqui embaixo
qual foi a história de menina com o doce
o menino também podolski mim também mas
escudou se meu o meu né amargo não é bom
né
sim é claro assim a rapadura e vai poder
ser seguido até aqui segue no instagram
é que o facebook segue no twitter minha
equipa e tanque pé ou se excedendo
barein nós nós levantar de novo porque
hoje nós é
edinho
a amigos e foi polga avaliou eu não
pagava de playboy só porque estava na
moda e você porta infância
agora daqui ou ligando pra você pra
pedir pra si o que é feito lá u
[Aplausos]
tudo ajuda das ruas